biologist Zeb Hogan is getting a
close-up look at one of the world's
largest freshwater fishes the Chinese
sturgeon fish and its tails free so it
can really whip around the sturgeons can
grow up to 16 feet or 5 meters long and
weigh almost 1,000 pounds
the Chinese sturgeon may be powerful but
this giant species is also in big
trouble
its home the Yangtze River in China
Asia's longest river is increasingly
threatened by heavy boat traffic and
pollution Hogan is leading the National
Geographic society's mega fishes project
a 3-year study to document the status of
the 20 or so species of giant fish found
in rivers and lakes around the world
more than a fifth of the world's known
freshwater fish species have become
extinct or gravely threatened in recent
years the construction of the gazoo ba
dam in the early 1980s blocked the
migration route to the spawning grounds
of the sturgeon today there may be fewer
than 1,000 adult sturgeons left in the
Yangtze River mega fishes are often the
first ones to suffer from overfishing or
habitat loss each year at least ten
sturgeons are also killed after being
hit by boat propellers the new Three
Gorges Dam the largest hydroelectric dam
in the world will present another threat
to these giant fish from the perspective
of a fish there's nothing that affects
the environment like a dam the Chinese
sturgeon now has no natural spawning
ground
in the Yangtze River researchers like
Wei Qi way of the gang see River
Fisheries Institute are locked in a race
against time to save the giant fish here
at a hatchery outside Jing su way and
his colleagues are running a breeding
program to enhance the sturgeon stock
half-a-million larvae produces how many
how many fish
how many can survive now we can survive
80% 80% so we thought 400,000 yeah
fingerlings researchers may yet save the
chinese sturgeon but for an even larger
Yangtze Giant the Chinese paddlefish it
may be too late in late 2002 dr. Wei and
his team attempted to rehabilitate one
of the last paddlefish is captured in
the wild it had been injured by a boat
and died in captivity less than 30 days
after its capture the paddlefish can
reportedly grow up to 23 feet or 7
meters long and weigh more than half a
ton but no paddlefish has been seen
since 2003 no fish probably uses a fish
finally finds the could be edge and his
pet fish we find there's some signal
some signals his 60-foot research vessel
was equipped with a tank and a crane
ready to rescue any giant fish that he
might find if the search fails this may
be the closest we'll ever get to see the
Chinese paddlefish again